all right for more on this we're joined
Now by national border patrol council
president Brandon Jud Brandon you just
heard Dana Marine McNichol report there
from Eagle Pass where I've spent pretty
much uh the majority of the back end of
2023 the numbers are down right now but
uh I'm not buying it that it's about to
slow significantly down as secretary
blinkin was telling a bunch of
dignitaries from Mexico that they've had
a recent drop uh and it's likely a trend
that's going to be going forward what do
you make of it yeah I smiled because I
know how long you have been down there
reporting on this and it's great to see
you down there every single time our
agents are very happy to see reporters
down there actually talking about this
but when we talk about Blink and when we
talk about my orus when we talk about
meetings with with Mexican officials
they're just not going to prove fruitful
we know that we can control everything
that happens here then you of course you
listen to what President Biden said he
said the border is not secure but then
he talks about the wrong wrong thing he
talks about money we don't need money
for this issue if President Biden was
seriously concerned about this issue all
he would have to do is give us policy he
doesn't have to have Congress give us
laws yes it would be nice to have those
laws because that's a long-term fix but
President Biden could fix this
immediately with policy we saw that with
President trump it was brilliant what he
did to drop illegal immigration of 45e
lows Biden could do the exact same thing
he doesn't have to have Congress step in
it's interesting and worth pointing out
I think Brandon that in that moment that
you saw in Lucas Thomson's report
President Biden saying no the border is
not secure it hasn't been for 10 years
and he says he's been saying that ever
since well here's a little bit of what
his administration has been saying for
him stands quite in contrast
watch I want to be very clear our
borders are not open the border is
secure the president has done more to
secure the border and to deal with this
issue of immigration than anybody else
so let's just set the record straight is
the Border open or is it closed is it
secure or is it insecure
Brandon so we what we have to talk about
when we talk about an open border is who
controls it what sections are being
controlled and right now there are
sections of our border that are being
controlled by the cartels all you have
to do is look at the goway numbers look
at the the amount of drugs that are on
our streets today that clearly shows
that the border is not secure and then
look at how the cartels operate they
flood our resources pull our agents out
of the field create gaps in our coverage
and that's when they cross their their
higher value products that clearly shows
that the border is not secure that's the
evidence those are facts those facts are
irrefutable and those facts clearly show
that the that the border is not secure
and that the border is in fact open at
specific times that the cartels want to
open the border and when you hear the uh
Administration saying that they're doing
things now to bring these numbers down
my source is in the Darian Gap in Panama
the
Panamanian uh immigration folks if you
will tell me as recent is yesterday that
they are seeing a trend they are
expecting a greater number of migrants
coming in 2024 then in 2023 which was
record-breaking what are you hearing
yeah all of our Intel points that
everything is going up look at the past
two days we just surpassed 5,000
apprehensions of the border patrol alone
CBP as a whole just under 7,000
apprehensions in the last few days those
numbers are going to continue to go up
if you look at what our numbers are in
December compared to past December we're
at record-breaking um levels so yes the
numbers are going to continue to go up
the only thing that is going to drive
these numbers down is if the cartels
recognize that President Trump is going
to be very very bad for them this is a
business they recognize that they have
to generate profit do they scale back
trying to make this less of an issue for
President Biden going into 2024 um or do
they just continue saying hey it's a
foregone conclusion Trump is going to
win let's generate as much profit as we
can right now it's all up to the cartels
The Mexican government is not going to
do anything they have no incentive to do
anything right now because of the amount
of money that goes into their Economy
based upon illegal immigration and drug
smuggling and and lastly Brandon before
we run out of time here when are we
going to get that official number I was
able to break with my sources that we
got 302,000 migrants apprehended in the
month of December but yet here we are on
January 20th and they still haven't
released the official number yeah DHS
always hides those numbers because they
don't want the American public to
understand what's going on they don't
want to have that honest conversation so
that we can make an informed decision
about everything that's going on we
don't get those numbers until they
actually publish them um based upon what
our apprehensions are but they're not
going to tell people what's coming up
because they know that that's going to
hurt them politically it's unfortunate
that our government is not telling the
American people the honest truth a
little transparency would go a long way
I think Brandon Jud National border
patrol council president thank you very
much hey everyone I'm Emily compano
catch me and my co-hosts Harris vulner
and Kaylee mcki on outnumbered every
weekday at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or set
your DVR also don't forget to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights